[Music]
what is it about our way of inhabiting
our own agency that makes us so directed
towards future states of affairs that we
don't completely control whether or not
they come about so you know these are
things that may happen there are things
that we can work towards but we never
have any guarantee that they will happen
and yet we invest a lot of our energy in
that I've come to think of the of that
it's a very special and characteristic
feature of our own human agency that we
are structured in that way we just do
not have very fulfilling or happy human
lives if we are not directing our agency
our energy toward those those
anticipated events hoped for of it when
we think about human development we're a
very atypical kind of species insofar as
when we're born unlike most other
species we have very little self
standing capacity to survive in the
world we need other people we need our
parents we need other caregivers to help
us develop the kinds of skills or
capacities we need to be able to survive
to be able to flourish in our world so
we we rely on others to give us those
skills to teach us those skills to
enable us to become fully fledged
autonomous individuals and that process
is a long drawn-out one and it involves
a certain important relationship with
our caregivers that they're able to
structure our environment in such a way
that they bring us little by little into
certain rather complex sorts of
engagements with the world allowing us
little by little to build up our
capacities for linguistic engagement for
the kind of skills we need to play with
toys
when you think about very early
development and the way a mother may be
interacting with her child showing the
child how to handle you know a toy or
something so the child now comes to be
able to do it for him or herself those
are very small acts but those are the
way we build up all our skills through
our long protracted development and
that's what psychologists have called
parental scaffolding that we treat our
infants as if they're capable of doing
things that they're not quite yet
capable of but we're structuring a world
for them in which they're able to try
and explore their limitations and maybe
be frustrated at times but slowly little
by little learn how to do things for
themselves that they couldn't do
initially
[Music]